hi everyone
welcome to this video tutorial on
machine learning projects by simply
learn
in this video we will cover some of the
crucial topics related to machine
learning and explore the different
algorithms that are widely used to solve
machine learning tasks and then we look
at several machine learning projects
which are very interesting so here is
the agenda for today's session
we will begin by learning the basics of
machine learning and then we will
explore about linear regression analysis
followed by logistic regression with
hands-on
demo sessions in python
next we will understand about decision
tree and random forest
after that we are going to learn about
support vector machines k-nearest
neighbors and k-means clustering with
hands-on demo in
python programming
moving ahead we'll learn how to predict
coronavirus cases using
several algorithms in machine learning
next we'll explore about the stock
market analysis and then
we'll look at an exploratory data
analysis about the world happiness
report
followed by understanding how you can
use
election data to make united states
election prediction we will wind up this
session by learning about
time series in r and then we look at
german credit and college admission
project what is machine learning hello
my name is richard kirchner i'm with the
simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead today we're
covering what is machine learning what's
in it for you we're going to cover the
basics of machine learning what is
machine learning artificial intelligence
versus machine learning versus deep
learning how does machine learning work
types of machine learning machine
learning pre-requisites applications of
machine learning
here we have our it looks a little bit
like frankenstein our frankenstein
looking robot today let me tell you what
is machine learning machine learning
works on the development of computer
programs that can access data and use it
to automatically learn and improve from
experience watch a robot builder
construct a house in two days this was
back in july 29
2016 so that's pretty impressive this
amount of time to continue to grow in
his development and it's smart enough to
leave spaces in the brickwork for wiring
and plumbing and can even cut and shape
bricks to size
amazon echo relies on machine learning
and with more data it becomes more
accurate play your favorite music order
pizza from domino's voice control your
home request rides from uber have you
ever wondered the difference between ai
machine learning and deep learning
artificial intelligence a technique
which enables machines to mimic human
behavior this is really important
because this is how we are able to gauge
how well our computations or what we're
working on works is the fact that we're
mimicking human behavior we're using
this to replace human work and make it
more efficient and make it more
streamlined and more accurate and so the
center of artificial intelligence is the
big picture of all this put together ibm
deep blue chess electronic game
characters those are just a couple
examples of artificial intelligence
machine learning a technique which uses
statistical methods enabling machines to
learn from their past data so this means
if you have your input from last time
and you have your answer you use that to
help prove the next guess it makes for
the correct answer ibm watson google
search algorithm email spam filters
these are all part of machine learning
and then deep learning which is a subset
of machine learning composing algorithms
that allow a model to train itself and
perform tasks
alphago natural speech recognition these
are a couple examples deep learning is
associated with tools like neural
networks where it's kind of a black box
as it learns it changes all these things
that are as a human we would have a very
hard time tracking and it's able to come
up with an answer from that now let's
see how machine learning works
first we start with training the data
once we've trained the data
the train we go into the machine
learning algorithm which then puts the
data into a processing which then goes
down to machine another machine learning
algorithm and then we take new data
because you have to test whatever you
did to make sure it works correctly and
we put that into the same algorithm once
we do that we check our prediction we
check our results and from the
prediction if we've set aside some
training date and we find out it didn't
do a good job predicting it and it gets
a thumbs down as you see then we go back
to the beginning and we retrain the
algorithm and a lot of times it's not
just about getting the wrong answer it's
about continually trying to get a better
answer so you'll see the first time you
might be like oh this is not the answer
i want depending on what domain you're
working in whether it's medical
economical business stocks whatever you
try out your model and if it's not
giving you a good answer you retrain it
if you think you can get a better answer
you retrain it and you keep doing that
until you get the best answer you can
let's see the types of machine learning
supervised learning unsupervised
learning there's a number of ways to
divide up machine learning and how it
works these are two main categories you
can divide it into supervised learning
we have a known amount of data so in
this case we have a bunch of apples we
have a machine learning algorithm it
goes through the process it goes through
and trains the model based on that known
data and then once you've trained your
model on the known stuff you can then
put an unknown data in there and you get
a new response and of course in this
particular one it's an apple so it's
trying to figure out whether it's an
apple or another fruit there are many
different algorithms you can use for
computing this information for doing
this supervised training just to list
the some of the top ones are currently
being used and by no means not there's
more than just this so by no means this
isn't the complete list there's
polynomial regression there's a random
forest there's linear regression there's
logistic regression there's decision
trees there's k-nearest neighbors and
there's naive bayes like i said this is
just a short list of some of the many
tools that are out there nowadays and if
you have supervised learning then we
should also look at unsupervised
learning unsupervised learning so we
have unknown data in this case you can
see we have a bunch of fruit and we
might not have labeled it we don't know
we've never had anybody look at it and
say this is what this is and we take
that data and we put it through the
machine learning algorithm and then that
goes through the processing and then the
trained model and with the trained model
says hey can i see a pattern here and
from that pattern it divides it up into
a response in this case apples and pairs
you can see some of these things look
just like the other and it tries to put
them all together so that you get
similar things in similar groups and
again we have a nice list of algorithms
here and this is not the only algorithms
used for this so don't limit yourself to
this just these these are just some of
the primary ones used today and of
course we have the k-means clustering
singular value decomposition fuzzy means
partial least squares a priori
hierarchical clustering principle
component analysis machine learning
pre-requisites computer science
fundamentals and programming so any of
the machine learning out today you have
to know some basic scripting or
programming intermediate statistical
knowledge you have to understand a
little bit about probabilities if a is
current how likely is b going to happen
if there's clouds overhead how likely is
it going to rain
linear algebra and intermediate calculus
the linear algebra is very important
because you have to understand basically
drawing a line through the data points
and what that means that's the most
fundamental linear regression models you
draw a line through all your data and
you use that line to compute new values
intermediate calculus means you need to
have a little bit of understanding of
what a differential equation is you
really don't need to be an expert
because the computer does all the heavy
lifting for you but it's important to
know the terms when they come up unless
you're doing some advanced programming
on the actual models themselves and data
wrangling and cleaning i would say this
might be the biggest one in here is you
have to start getting a grip on how to
clean up your data there's a saying is
bad data in bad data out good data in
you're more likely to have good data out
some applications of machine learning
instance segmentation object detection
instant segmentation you can see here
where they use machine learning to go in
there and find where the different cats
are and the different objects are in the
picture and then in segmentation it
actually cuts them out kind of a fun one
especially if you have a google pixel
phone and you can do little animation
objects on top of your ongoing pictures
you're taking or movies
number plate detection you can see here
where we have a card it comes in there
and it finds a number plate on the car
once it's done that it can then do
automatic translation automatic
translation is we pick up some symbols
in this case on a machine and it does
machine translation so that you can know
what it's saying even if you don't speak
that language let's look at another
example machine learning based on the
amount of rainfall how much would be the
crop yield so here we have our crops we
have our rainfall and we want to know
how much we're going to get from our
crops this year so we're going to
introduce two variables independent and
dependent the independent variable is a
variable whose value does not change by
the effect of other variables and is
used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as x in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary height where categorical
would be a description the color a dog's
breed gender categorical is limited to
very specific items where numerical
is a range of information now that
you've seen the difference between
numerical and categorical data let's
take a look at some different machine
learning definitions we look at our
different machine learning algorithms we
can divide them into three areas
supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why we multiple linear
regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today
housing sales to estimate the number of
houses a builder would sell and what
price in the coming months
score predictions cricket fever to
predict the number of runs a player
would score in the coming matches based
on the previous performance i'm sure you
can figure out other applications you
could use linear regression for so let's
jump in and let's understand linear
regression and dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get since linear regression
is based on drawing a line through data
we're going to jump back and take a look
at some euclidean geometry the simplest
form of a simple linear regression
equation with one dependent and one
independent variable is represented by y
equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and x being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever x is m
in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y
y2 minus y1 and x2 minus x1 and finally
we have c which is the coefficient of
the line or where it happens to cross
the zero axis
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math that
you're going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate here we're going to dig
deeper into the math behind the
regression line now remember before i
said you don't have to have all these
formulas memorized or fully understand
them even though we're going to go into
a little more detail of how it works and
if you're not a math wiz and you don't
know if you've never seen the sigma
character before which looks a little
bit like an e
that's opened up that just means
summation that's all that is so when you
see the sigma character it just means
we're adding everything in that row and
for computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the x y points and
create all the information you need so
in the top half you can see where we've
broken that down into pieces and as it
goes through the first two points it
computes the squared value of x the
squared value of y and x times y and
then it takes all of x and adds them up
all of y adds them up all of x squared
adds them up and so on and so on and you
can see we have the sum of equal to 15
the sum is equal to 20 all the way up to
x times y where the sum equals 66. this
all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope times x plus the
coefficient c so we go down below and
we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we're going to
explain exactly what that is in just a
minute and where that information comes
from is called the square means error
but we'll go into that in detail in a
few minutes all you need to do is look
at the formula and see how we've gone
about computing it line by line instead
of trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum
of x times y which we computed one line
at a time there and that's just the 66
and take all that and you subtract it
from the sum of x times the sum of y and
those have both been computed so you
have 15 times 20. and on the bottom we
have the number of lines times the sum
of x squared easily computed as 86 for
the sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values and we're going to go ahead and
plot them we're going to predict them so
y equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit line should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart we can see x
and you can see why what we actual
values were and you can see why predict
it you can easily see where we take y
minus y predicted and we get an answer
what is the difference between those two
and if we square that y minus y
prediction squared we can then sum those
squared values that's where we get the
0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the way
down until we have a summation equals
2.4 so the sum of squared errors for
this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and include the
best fit line having the least e square
value in a nice graphical representation
we can see here where we keep moving
this line through the data points to
make sure the best fit line has the
least square distance between the data
points and the regression line now we
only looked at the most commonly used
formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic multiple linear
regression let's take a brief look at
what happens when you have multiple
inputs so in multiple linear regression
we have well we'll start with the simple
linear regression where we had y equals
m plus x plus c and we're trying to find
the value of y now with multiple linear
regression we have multiple variables
coming in so instead of having just x we
have x1 x2 x3 and instead of having just
one slope each variable has its own
slope attached to it as you can see here
we have m1 m2 m3 and we still just have
the single coefficient so when you're
dealing with multiple linear regression
you basically take your single linear
regression and you spread it out so you
have y equals m1 times x1 plus m2 times
x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its r d trying
to figure out his profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs
marketing costs and so on and from there
we're going to see if we can figure out
what the profit of that company is going
to be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it it's such
a visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupiter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber signed
library inline that is only because i'm
doing an inline ide my interface in the
anaconda jupiter notebook requires i put
that in there or you're not going to see
the graph when it comes up let's go
ahead and run this it's not going to be
that interesting so we're just setting
up variables in fact it's not going to
do anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies dot csv you're
going to have to change this to fit
whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request
just go down to the commentary below
this video and put a note in there and
simply learn we'll try to get in contact
with you and supply you with that file
so you can try this coding yourself so
we're going to add this code in here and
we're going to see that i have companies
equals pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the ilocation
and because this is companies as a pd
data set i can use this nice notation
that says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus 1 and we want the values set into
there so x is no longer a data set a
pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the panda sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carrier's
return i don't know about you but i'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents compared
to the administration cost of
six thousand eight hundred ninety seven
dollars and eighty cents so on so on
helps to create the profit of 192 261
and 83 cents that makes no sense to me
whatsoever no pun intended so let's flip
back here and take a look at our next
set of code where we're going to graph
it so we can get a better understanding
of our data and what it means so at this
point we're going to use a single line
of code to get a lot of information so
we can see where we're going with this
let's go ahead and paste that into our
notebook and see what we got going and
so we have the visualization and again
we're using sns which is pandas as you
can see we imported the map plot library
dot pi plot as plt which then the
seaborn uses and we imported the seaborn
as sns and then that final line of code
helps us show this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file in other means and that's the
matplot library in line with the amber
sign at the beginning so here we come
down to the single line of code seaborn
is great because it actually recognizes
the panda data frame so i can just take
the companies dot core for coordinates
and i can put that right into the
seaborn and when we run this we get this
beautiful plot and let's just take a
look at what this plot means if you look
at this plot on mine the colors are
probably a little bit more purplish and
blue than the original one uh we have
the columns and the rows we have r and d
spinning we have administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r and d spending is
going to be the same as r and d spending
and the same thing with administration
costs right down the middle you get this
dark row or dark um diagonal row that
shows that this is the highest
corresponding data that's exactly the
same and as it becomes lighter there's
less connections between the data so we
can see with profit obviously profit is
the same as profit and next it has a
very high correlation with r d spending
which we looked at earlier and it has a
slightly less connection to marketing
spending and even less to how much money
we put into the administration so now
that we have a nice look at the data
let's go ahead and dig in and create
some actual useful linear regression
models so that we can predict values and
have a better profit now that we've
taken a look at the visualization of
this data we're going to move on to the
next step instead of just having a
pretty picture we need to generate some
hard data some hard values so let's see
what that looks like we're going to set
up our linear regression model in two
steps the first one is we need to
prepare some of our data so it fits
correctly and let's go ahead and paste
this code into our jupyter notebook and
what we're bringing in is we're going to
bring in the sklearn pre-processing
where we're going to import the label
encoder and the one hot encoder to use
the label encoder we're going to create
a variable called label encoder and set
it equal to capital l label capital e
encoder this creates a class that we can
reuse for transferring the labels back
and forth now about now you should ask
what labels are we talking about let's
go take a look at the data we processed
before and see what i'm talking about
here if you remember when we did the
companies dot head and we printed the
top five rows of data we have our
columns going across we have column zero
which is r and d spending column one
which is administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is state and you'll see
under state we have new york california
florida now to do a linear regression
model it doesn't know how to process new
york it knows how to process a number so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to change that new york
california and florida and we're going
to change those to numbers that's what
this line of code does here x equals and
then it has the colon comma 3 in
brackets the first part the colon comma
means that we're going to look at all
the different rows so we're going to
keep them all together but the only row
we're going to edit is the third row and
in there we're going to take the label
coder and we're going to fit and
transform the x also the third row so
we're going to take that third row we're
going to set it equal to a
transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or a one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
as just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look at what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if i go ahead
and just do row 0 you'll see i have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computers
automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transformed all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models you usually see that a
capital x and you see the train and the
test and the lower case y what this is
is x is our data going in that's our rnd
span our administration our marketing
and then y which we're training is the
answer that's the profit because we want
to know the profit of an unknown entity
that's what we're going to shoot for in
this tutorial the next part train test
split we take x and we take y we've
already created those x has the columns
with the data in it and y has a column
with profit in it and then we're going
to set the test size equals point two
that basically means twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're going to put them off
to the side so since we're using a
thousand lines of data that means that
200 of those lines we're going to hold
off to the side to test for later and
then the random state equals zero we're
going to randomize which ones it picks
to hold off to the side we'll go ahead
and run this it's not overly exciting so
setting up our variables but the next
step is the next step we actually create
our linear regression model now that we
got to the linear regression model we
get that next piece of the puzzle let's
go ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn dot linear underscore model
we're going to import linear regression
now i don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
where we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization and then we also looked at
setting it up with the different lines
and then we also looked all the way down
to multiple linear regression where
we're adding all those formulas together
all of that is wrapped up in this one
section so what's going on here is i'm
going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually and then we do the
regressor.fit in this case we do x train
and y train because we're using the
training data x being the data in and y
being profit what we're looking at and
this does all that math for us so within
one click and one line we've created the
whole linear regression model and we fit
the data to the linear regression model
and you can see that when i run the
regressor it gives an output linear
regression it says copy x equals true
fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false it's just
giving you some general information on
what's going on with that regressor
model now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it and if you remember we kept a bunch
of data aside so we're going to do a y
predict variable and we're going to put
in the x test and let's see what that
looks like scroll up a little bit paste
that in here predicting the test set
results so here we have y predict equals
regressor dot predict x test going in
and this gives us y predict now because
i'm in jupiter inline i can just put the
variable up there and when i hit the run
button it'll print that array out i
could have just as easily done print
why predict so if you're in a different
ide that's not an inline setup like the
jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side it's going to produce
200 answers this is what it says the
profit are for those 200 predictions but
let's don't stop there let's keep going
and take a couple look we're going to
take just a short detail here and
calculating the coefficients and the
intercepts this gives us a quick flash
at what's going on behind the line
we're going to take a short detour here
and we're going to be calculating the
coefficient and intercepts so you can
see what those look like what's really
nice about our regressor we created is
it already has a coefficients for us we
can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient underscore when i run this
you'll see our coefficients here and if
we can do the regressor coefficient we
can also do the regressor intercept and
let's run that and take a look at that
this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into where it's coming from you can see
the formula down here where y equals m1
times x1 plus m2 times x2 and so on and
so on plus c the coefficient so these
variables fit right into this formula y
equals slope 1 times column 1 variable
plus slope 2 times column 2 variable all
the way to the m to the n and x to the n
plus c the coefficient or in this case
you have minus 8.89
to the power of 2 etc etc times the
first column and the second column and
the third column and then our intercept
is the minus 1 0 3 0 0 9 point boy it
gets kind of complicated when you look
at it this is why we don't do this by
hand anymore this is why we have the
computer to make these calculations easy
to understand and calculate now i told
you that was a short detour and we're
coming towards the end of our script as
you remember from the beginning i said
if we're going to divide this
information we have to make sure it's a
valid model that this model works and
understand how good it works so
calculating the r squared value that's
what we're going to use to predict how
good our prediction is and let's take a
look what that looks like in code and so
we're going to use this from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 correct but you do want that in
the upper 90s oh and higher shows that
this is a very valid prediction based on
the r2 score and if r squared value of
0.91 or 9 2 as we got on our model
remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression all right what
is logistic regression as i mentioned
earlier positive regression is an
algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the x and y axis x is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between zero and one and as we
can imagine it is intuitive as well as
the number of years are on the lower
side maybe one year two years or three
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down the probability
of your car breaking down within two
years of your last service are 0.1
probability similarly 3 years is maybe
0.3 and so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was 6 or 7
years there is almost a certainty that
your car is going to break down that is
what this graph shows so this is an
example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variables outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about so
here the outcome is discrete and not a
continuous value so this is how the
logistic regression curve looks let me
explain a little bit what exactly how
exactly we are going to
uh determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be set saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be zero or
one but based on the probability we need
to decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say
an output of 0.29 is considered as 0
which means that the car will not break
down so that's the way logistic
regression works now let's do a quick
comparison between logistic regression
and linear regression because they both
have the term regression in them so it
can cause confusion so let's try to
remove that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say the hr team
of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is trained and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employees information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be the high so this is a linear
regression problem
linear regression example now salary is
a continuous value you can get five
thousand five thousand five hundred
five thousand six hundred it is not
discrete like a cat or a dog or an apple
or a banana these are discrete or a yes
or no these are discrete values right so
this way you're trying to find
continuous values is where we use linear
regression so let's say just to extend
on the scenario we now want to find out
whether this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
that is a discrete problem right a yes
or no kind of a problem in this case we
actually cannot use
linear regression even though we may
have labeled data so this is the label
data so based on the employee rating
these are the ratings and then some
people got the promotion and this is the
ratings for which people did not get
promotion that is a no and this is the
rating for which people got promotion we
just plotted the data about whether a
person has got an employer's got
promotion or not yes no right so there
is nothing in between and what is the
employees rating okay and ratings can be
continuous that is not an issue but the
output is discrete in this case whether
employee got promotion yes no okay so if
we try to plot that and we try to find a
straight line this is how it would look
and as you can see it doesn't look very
right because looks like there will be
lot of errors this root mean square
error if you remember for linear
regression would be very very high and
also the the values cannot go beyond
zero or beyond one so the graph should
probably look somewhat like this clipped
at zero and one but still the straight
line doesn't look right therefore
instead of using a linear equation we
need to come up with something different
and therefore the logistic regression
model looks somewhat like this so we
calculate the probability and if we plot
that probability
not in the form of a straight line but
we need to use some other equation we
will see very soon what that equation is
then it is a gradual process right so
you see here people with some of these
ratings are not getting any promotions
and then slowly
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and
this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is one minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from 0 to
infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to 0 and when the probability
becomes 1 then the value of the odds is
1 by 0 that will be infinity but the
probability itself remains between 0 and
1. now this is how an equation of a
straight line looks so y is equal to
beta0 plus beta 1 x where beta0 is the y
intercept and beta 1 is the slope of the
line if we take the odds equation and
take a log of both sides then this would
look somewhat like this and the term
logistic is actually derived from the
fact that we are doing this we take a
log of px by 1 minus px this is an
extension of the calculation of odds
that we have seen right and that is
equal to beta 0 plus beta 1 x which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of p x you will see we can
take the exponential on both sides and
then if we solve that equation we will
get the equation of p x like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta 0 plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation
also known as the sigmoid function and
this is the equation of the logistic
regression all right and if this is
plotted this is how the sigmoid curve is
obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
it's going to be sunny or not but it's
going to snow or not these are all
logistic regression examples a few more
examples classification of objects this
is a again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupiter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and there the image has a number
one two three four and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's take a
look at the code and see what we are
doing so i will not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images are
a sample of these images and
then we split the data into training and
test as i mentioned earlier and we can
do some exploratory analysis and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we go we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right
so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 percent because the diagonals should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagonals the cells other
than the diagonal should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a 2 here there are there is
a 1 here but most of them are along the
diagonal this what does this mean this
means that the
number that has been fed is zero and the
number that has been detected is also
zero so the predicted value and the
actual value are the same so along the
diagonals that is true which means that
let's let's take this diagonal right if
the maximum number is here that means
that like here in this case it is 34
which means that 34 of the images that
have been fed or rather actually there
are two misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four and out of which 34 have
been predicted correctly as number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight and another one has been predicted
as number nine so these are two
misclassifications okay so that is the
meaning of saying that the maximum
number should be in the diagonal so if
you have all of them so for an ideal
model which has let's say 100 accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
hundred percent accurate model okay so
that's uh just of how to use this matrix
uh how to use this confusion matrix i
know the name
is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix but actually it is not very
confusing it's very straightforward so
you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and actually that's all it is okay yeah
so we are showing a little bit more
information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and the
predicted value and the actual value is
exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are i think 37 plus 5
yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of digit 3 and
the accuracy is only 37 of them have
been accurately predicted three of them
have been predicted as number seven and
two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see how the code
looks so this is the code in
in jupiter notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code then here we will
visualize the shape of these digits so
we can see here if we take a look this
is how the shape is 1797
by 64. these are like eight by eight
images so that's that's what is
reflected in this shape now from here
onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at
some of the sample images that we have
loaded so this one for example creates a
figure and then we go ahead and take a
few sample images to see how they look
so let me run this code and so that it
becomes easy to understand so these are
about five images sample images that we
are looking at zero one two three four
so this is how the image is this is how
the data is okay and uh based on this we
will actually train our logistic
regression model and then we will test
it and see how well it is able to
recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an 8 by 8 pixel kind of a
image and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn
for which a number what is the pattern
of the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training we split the data
into training and test so that the
training data set is used to train the
system so we pass this probably multiple
times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of the and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20.23
that means 23 percent of that entire
data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is uh called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train and y underscore train
for the training data set and what is x
underscore train these are these are the
features right which is like the
independent variable and why underscore
train is the label right so in this case
what happens is we have the input value
which is or the features value which is
in x underscore train and since this is
the labeled data for each of them each
of the observations we already have the
label information saying whether this
digit is a zero or a one or a two so
that this is what will be used for
comparison to find out whether the the
system is able to recognize it correctly
or there is an error for each
observation it will compare with this
right so this is the label so the same
way x underscore train y underscore
train is for the training data set x
underscore test y underscore test is for
the test data set okay so let me go
ahead and execute this code as well and
then we can go and check quickly what is
the how many entries are there and in
each of these so x underscore train the
shape is 13 83
by 64. and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape
we see is 414 so actually there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library and
which is a part of scikit learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line
is where we are passing our data the
training data set and this is our the
the predictors and
this is our target we are passing this
data set to train our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and we want
to see how accurate this is so what
we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for a particular
value new input you use the predict
method okay so let's run the predict
method and we pass this particular image
and
we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10
seems to be fine so let me just go ahead
and test the entire data set okay that's
basically what it will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentages of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 percent accurate okay so that's on
this part now what we can also do is we
can
also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well
so that we can also visualize how well
this model has
done
so let me execute this piece of code
which will basically import some of the
libraries that are required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix an instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix
and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers uh which means the accuracy is
very low the diagonal indicates a
correct prediction that this means that
the actual value is same as the
predicted value here again actual values
same as the predictive value and so on
right so the moment you see a number
here that means the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else right similarly here the
actual value is something and the
predicted value is something else so
that is basically how we read the
confusion matrix now how do we find the
accuracy you can actually add up the
total values in the diagonal so it's
like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so on and
divide that by the total number of test
observations that will give you the
percentage accuracy using a confusion
matrix now let us visualize this
confusion matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way
using a heat map so we will create a
heat map with some we'll add some colors
as well it's uh it's like a more
visually visually more appealing so
that's the whole idea so if we let me
run this piece of code and this is how
the heat map looks uh and as you can see
here the diagonals again are all the
values are here most of the values so
which means reasonably this seems to be
reasonably accurate and yeah basically
the accuracy score is 94 percent this is
calculated as i mentioned by adding all
these numbers divided by the total test
values or the total number of
observations in test data set okay
so this is the confusion matrix for
logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we we picked up randomly a few of them
so this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero actual
value is of course zero
then this is the image of nine
so this has also been predicted
correctly 9 and actual value is 9 and
this is the image of 1 and again this
has been predicted correctly as like the
actual value okay so this was a quick
demo of logistic regression how to use
logistic regression to identify
images
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in d
decision tree is a tree shape diagram
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision or currents or
reaction let's start with a simple
question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is the diameter greater than 2 if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
and the different parts we're going to
be using we'll start with entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went on
the different parts of our tree and they
call the leaf node leaf node carries the
classification or the decision so it's
the final end at the bottom the decision
node has two or more branches this is
where we're breaking the group up into
different parts and finally you have the
root node the topmost decision node is
known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals all get the jungle
today maybe you're the hunter with a gun
or if you're more into photography
you're a photographer with a camera so
let's look at this group of animals and
let's try to classify different types of
animals based on their features using a
decision tree so the problem statement
is to classify the different types of
animals based on their features using a
decision tree the data set is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so let's look at a training
set or a training data set and we're
looking at color we're looking at height
and then we have our different animals
we have our elephants our giraffes our
monkeys and our tigers and they're of
different colors and shapes let's see
what that looks like and how do we split
the data we have to frame the conditions
that split the data in such a way that
the information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decreasing
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base two of
the same the percentage of that animal
let's try to calculate the entropy for
the current data set and take a look at
what that looks like and don't be afraid
of the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three drafts
a total of eight times the log usually
they use base two on the log so log base
two of three over eight plus in this
case this hits yellow fence two over
eight two elephants over total of eight
times log base two two over eight plus
one monkey over total of eight log base
two one over eight and plus two over
eight of the tigers log base two over
eight and if we plug that into our
computer or calculator i obviously can't
do logs in my head we get an entropy
equal to
0.571 the program will actually
calculate the entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not going to go
through each set one at a time to see
what those numbers are we just want you
to be aware that this is a formula or
the mathematics behind it gain can be
calculated by finding the difference of
the subsequent entropy values after a
split now we'll try to choose a
condition that gives us the highest gain
we will do that by splitting the data
using each condition and checking that
the gain we get out of them the
condition that gives us the highest gain
will be used to make the first split can
you guess what that first split will be
just by looking at this image as a human
is probably pretty easy to split it
let's see if you're right if you guessed
the color yellow you're correct let's
say the condition that gives us the
maximum gain is yellow so we will split
the data based on the color yellow if
it's true that group of animals goes to
the left if it's false it goes to the
right the entropy after the splitting
has
decreased considerably however we still
need some splitting of both the branches
to attain an entropy value equal to zero
so we decide to split both the nodes
using height as a condition since every
branch now contains single label type we
can say that entropy in this case has
reached the least value and here you see
we have the giraffes the tigers the
monkey and the elephants all separated
into their own groups this tree can now
predict all the classes of animals
present in the dataset with a hundred
percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for his bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupyter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics for accuracy score we
need to score our our setup that's the
whole reason we're splitting it between
the training and testing data and
finally we still need the sklearn import
tree and that's just the basic tree
function is needed for the decision tree
classifier and finally we're going to
load our data down here and i'm going to
run this and we're going to get two
things on here one we're going to get an
error and two we're going to get a
warning let's see what that looks like
so the first thing we had is we have an
error why is this error here well it's
looking at this it says i need to read a
file and when this was written
the person who wrote it this is their
path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name
and you'll see it's on my c drive and
this is very lengthy setup on here where
i stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer will be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn if you want a copy of that
you can comment down below and request
it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sklearn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet this
is what it looks like as a basic text
file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score house
number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head this is one of
the nice things when we did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a
row and then shows the data separate it
does a good job sorting that data out
for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
panda's print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and when we run that
let's just take a closer look at that
let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head it prints the first five lines of
the data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
excel spreadsheet or open office cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
date ahead you can actually see what
this data looks like the initial payment
last payment credit scores house number
so let's take this now that we've
explored the data and let's start
digging into the decision tree so in our
next step we're going to train and build
our data tree and to do that we need to
first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at its source and
target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines in the database so it's all the
data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero zero
is a yes or no
and that's whether the loan went default
or not so we want to start with one if
we go back up here that's the initial
payment and it goes all the way through
the house number
well if we want to look at 1 through 5
we can do the same thing for y which is
the answers and we're going to set that
just equal to the zero row so it's just
the zero row and then it's all rows
going in there so now we've divided this
into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x trade or the y train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropal decision tree classifier it
automatically prints out what's in that
decision tree there's a lot of variables
you can play within here and it's quite
beyond the scope of this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of three
now the max depth if you remember above
when we were doing the different graphs
of animals means it's only going to go
down three layers before it stops and
then we have minimal samples of leaves
is five so it's going to have at least
five leaves at the end so i'll have at
least three splits i'll have no more
than three layers and at least five end
leaves with the final result at the
bottom now that we've created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we
created and then you'll see dot predict
and it's very common in the sk learn
modules that their different tools have
the predict when you're actually running
a prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use and
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be uh pay
them back or not
in this case though we need to test out
the data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments and finally
since anaconda jupiter notebook is it
works as a command line for python we
can simply put the y predict e n to
print it i could just as easily have put
the print
and put brackets around y predict e in
to print it out we'll go ahead and do
that it doesn't matter which way you do
it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit is going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not so why random forest it's
always important to understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with
the random forest the first one is
there's no overfitting if you use of
multiple trees reduce the risk of
overfitting training time is less
overfitting means that we have fit the
data so close to what we have as our
sample that we pick up on all the weird
parts and instead of predicting the
overall data you're predicting the weird
stuff which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area and
they took a slightly different set of
statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then they can do a very good job of
guessing
which one fits better even though it's
missing that data let us dig deep into
the theory of exactly how it works and
let's look at what is a random forest
random forest or random decision forest
is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as a final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switched from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true then it comes
out as the orange and if it's false that
leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy everything on the
decision tree and how it makes those
decision is based on entropy entropy is
a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to sit
create a data set one and a data set two
we just split it in two and if you look
at these new
data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less
so for the first one
whatever comes in there it's going to
sort that data and it's going to say
okay if this data goes this direction
it's probably an apple and if it goes
into the other direction it's probably a
lemon so that brings us up to
information gain it is the measure of
decrease in the entropy after the data
set is split what that means in here is
that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals
decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set 1 or our set two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision we should
have a name for the nodes above it and
they call those decision nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons and one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the topmost decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split
let's look and see exactly what that
means to split the data and how do we
make those decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit
and so let's create a problem statement
and the problem is we want to classify
the different types of fruits in the
bowl based on different features the
data set in the bowl is looking quite
messy and the entropy is high in this
case so if this ball was our decision
maker it wouldn't know what choice to
make it has so many choices which one do
you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
three three one three three one and we
have a label apple lemon grapes apple
lemon grapes and how do we split the
data we have to frame the conditions to
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest it's
very key to note that we're looking for
the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hardy
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into that
range so our first split from our
decision node as we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at there
very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of 0
as you can see there's only one kind of
label left for this branch so no further
splitting is required for this node
however this node on the right is still
requires a split to decrease the entropy
further so we split the right node
further based on color if you look at
this if i split it on color that pretty
much cuts it right down the middle it's
the only thing we have left in our
choices of color and diameter too and if
the color is yellow it's going to go to
the right bowl and if it's false it's
going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with a hundred percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy along with our grapes up
there so we've looked at kind of a basic
tree in our forest but what we really
want to know is how does a random forest
work as a whole so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this just like we did in the
example this tree looks at the diameter
if it's greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange it's going to go to the
right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false we build a
second tree very similar but split
differently instead of the first one
being split by a diameter
this one when they created it if you
look at that first bowl it has a lot of
red objects so it says is the color red
because that's going to bring our
entropy down the fastest and so of
course if it's true it goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right and
then it looks at the shape false are
true and so on and so on and tree 3 is
the diameter equal to 1. and it came up
with this because there's a lot of
cherries in this bowl so that would be
the biggest split on there is is the
diameter equal to 1 that's going to drop
the entropy the quickest and as you can
see it splits it into true if it goes
false and they've added another category
does it grow in the summer and if it's
false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees you can see them
all in one image so this would be three
completely different trees categorizing
a fruit and let's take a fruit now let's
try this and this fruit if you look at
it we've blackened it out you can't see
the color on it so it's missing data
remember one of the things we talked
about earlier is that a random forest
works really good if you're missing data
if you're missing pieces so this fruit
has an image but maybe the person had a
black and white camera when they took
the picture and we're going to take a
look at this and it's going to have they
put the color in there so ignore the
color down there but the diameter equals
three we find out it grows in the summer
equals yes and the shape is a circle and
if you go to the right you can look at
what one of the decision trees did this
is the third one
is the diameter greater than equal to
three is the color orange well it
doesn't really know on this one but if
you look at the value it's a true and go
to the right tree 2 classifies it as
cherries is a color equal red
is the shape of circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry
when you add that all together the
majority of the vote says orange so the
answer is it's classified as an orange
even though we didn't know the color and
we're missing data on it i don't know
about you but i'm getting tired of fruit
so let's switch and i did promise you
we'd start looking at a case example and
get into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupyter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn.ensemble import random forest
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the
other modules that we bring in and one
is going to be pandas we're going to
import pandas as pd pd is a common term
used for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us
where when you create a pandas data
frame it looks like an excel spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code panda
is just wonderful because it plays nice
with all the other modules in there and
then we have numpy which is our numbers
python and the numbers python allows us
to do different mathematical sets on
here we'll see right off the bat we're
going to take our np and we're going to
go ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupyter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run
the imports and i'm going to paste the
code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if you
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet
and in this excel spreadsheet we have
set the columns so up on the top you can
see the four different columns and then
we have the data iris.data down below
it's a little confusing without knowing
where this data is coming from so let's
look at
the bigger picture and i'm going to go
print i'm just going to change this for
a moment and we're going to print all of
iris and see what that looks like
so when i print all a virus i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary
you'll have a key or a label and this
label pulls up whatever information
comes after it so feature names which we
actually used over here under columns is
equal to an array of sepal length simple
width petal length petal width these are
the different names they have for the
four different columns and if you scroll
down far enough you'll also see data
down here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head
it'll print the first five lines of the
dataset in there along with the headers
if you have it in this case we have the
column header set to iris features and
in here you'll see that we have 0 1 2 3
4 in python most arrays always start at
0. so when you look at the first 5 it's
going to be 0 1 2 3 4 not one two three
four five so now we've got our iris data
imported into a data frame let's take a
look at the next piece of code in here
and so in this section here of the code
we're gonna take a look at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupiter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here and
before i run it i want to look at a
couple things going on so we have df
species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target now these are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do either one i could have just as
easily done iris and then in brackets
target depending on what i'm working on
both are acceptable
let's go ahead and run this code and see
how this changes and what we've done is
we've added the target from the iris
data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're going to add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you that where you
where that's different where you can
alter that and do it slightly
differently but let's go ahead and put
this into our script up to debt now and
here we go we're going to put that down
here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for
numpy.random.uniform so we're generating
a random number between zero and one and
we're going to do it for each of the
rows that's where the length df comes
from so each row gets a generated number
and if it's less than 0.75 it's true and
if it's greater than 0.75 it's false
this means we're going to take
of the data roughly because there's a
randomness involved and we're going to
use that to train it and then the other
25 we're going to hold off to the side
and use that to test it later on so
let's flip back on over and see what the
next step is so now that we've labeled
our database for which is training and
which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test 75 in train 25 and
test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is trained equals true that's
going to go in the train and if df is
train equals false it goes in the test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 in one and
25 percent for us to test our model on
afterward so let's jump back to our code
and see where this goes in the next two
steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width pedal
length and pedal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupyter notebook or you're
running command line in the
terminal window if you just put the name
of it it'll print it out this is the
same as doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupiter notebooks
is i'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead and convert the species on
here into something the computer
understands so let's put this code into
our script and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd dot factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what's factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second let's look at what train species
is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa satoshi satosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and veracolor
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species
of zero because this is in the format of
a of an array of arrays so you have to
have the zero on the end and then
species is just that column factorize
goes in there looks at the fact
that there's only three of them so when
i run this you'll see that y generates
an array that's equal to in this case
it's the training set and it's zeros
ones and twos representing the three
different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
0 is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is a
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window on a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and it printed out y instead of print
y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these different meanings of
all these different settings on here
some of them are self-explanatory if you
kind of think about it a little bit like
max features is auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we have the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this we're looking at a
lot of stuff here so you might have in
this case there's probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf nodes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay you can only go so far and
then we're going to use all of our
resources on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is limiting the process and
making sure we don't uh overwhelm a
system and there's some other settings
in here again we're not going to go over
all of them warm start equals false warm
start is if you're programming it one
piece at a time externally since we're
not we're not going to have like we're
not going to continually to train this
particular learning tree and again like
i said there's a lot of things in here
that you'll want to look up more detail
from the sk learn and if you're digging
in deep and running a major project on
here for today though all we need to do
is fit our train our features and our
target y so now we have our training
model what's next if we're going to
create a model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length sepal width pedal length
petal width so when we put it in this
way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here so you can
see what features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5.2
and we're going to put those in and
we're going to predict what our
new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts 0 0 0 1 2 1 1 2 2 2
and and again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf.predict
probability so we're running it just
like we ran it up here but this time
with this we're going to get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here that this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a 1
for setosa it predicts a 0 for virginica
and it predicts a 0 for versa color and
so on and so on and so on and let's um
you know what i'm going to change this
just a little bit let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says setosa
gets zero votes virginica gets .5 votes
versus color gets 0.5 votes but let's
just go with the virginica since these
two are equal and so on and so on down
the list you can see how they vary on
here so now we've looked at both how to
do a basic predict of the features and
we've looked at the predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the the names that we've been
talking about this whole time the setosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run we could have just set a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we're going
to run it again clf dot predict test
features remember that returns the zeros
the ones and the twos and then we're
going to set that equal to predictions
so this time we're actually putting it
in a variable and when i run this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versa color
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together
the first one is our predictions and i
went ahead and did uh predictions
through 25 let's just do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species i remember i could have
just done test.species.head
and you'll see it says satosa satosa
satosa setosa and they match
so the first one is what our
forest is doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupiter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm going to because i'm on
the jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're going to create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas
and we're doing a cross tab this
function takes two sets of data and
creates a chart out of them so when i
run it you'll get a nice chart down here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
percent accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting before we wrap it up so let's
flip back on over to my script in here
we're going to take this line of code
from up above i don't know if you
remember it but predix equals the iris
dot target underscore names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
last week my son and i visited a fruit
shop dad is that an apple or a
strawberry so the question comes up what
fruit do they just pick up from the
fruit stand after a couple of seconds
you could figure out that it was a
strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh why not build
a model which can predict an unknown
data and in this we're going to be
looking at some sweet strawberries or
crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and already labeled as such
we already have a bunch of apples we
know our apples and are labeled as such
then once we train our model that model
then can be given the new data and the
new data is this image in this case you
can see a question mark on it and it
comes through and goes it's a strawberry
in this case we're using the support
vector machine model svm is a supervised
learning method that looks at data and
sorts it into one of two categories and
in this case we're sorting the
strawberry into the strawberry site at
this point you should be asking the
question how does the prediction work
before we dig into an example with
numbers let's apply this to our fruit
scenario we have our support vector
machine we've taken it and we've taken
labeled sample of data strawberries and
apples and we draw on a line down the
middle between the two groups this split
now allows us to take new data in this
case an apple and a strawberry and place
them in the appropriate group based on
which side of the line they fall in and
that way we can predict the unknown as
colorful and tasty as the fruit example
is let's take a look at another example
with some numbers involved and we can
take a closer look at how the math works
in this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set of female
where you have their height and weight
174 65 174 88 and so on and we'll need a
sample data set of the mail they have a
height 179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's
go ahead and put this on a graph so we
have a nice visual so you can see here
we have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we draw on two lines through the data in
the middle that separates them in from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as possible in technical terms we
can say the distance between the support
vector and the hyperplane should be as
far as possible and this is where the
support vectors are the extreme points
in the data set and if you look at this
data set they have circled two points
which seem to be right on the outskirts
of the woman and one on the outskirts of
the men and hyperplane has a maximum
distance to the support vectors of any
class now you'll see the line down the
middle and we call this the hyperplane
because when you're dealing with
multiple dimensions it's really not just
a line but a plane of intersections and
you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest negative point
which is on the women's side the sum of
d plus and d minus is called the
distance margin or the distance between
the two support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender hopefully that's clear how
that works on a visual level as a data
scientist you should also be asking what
happens if the hyperplane is not optimal
if we select a hyperplane having low
margin then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called referred to as the ls vm so
far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a 1d view of the data to
a two-dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1d input and
transfer it to a two-dimensional output
as you can see in this picture here the
1d when transferred to a 2-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets what if we
make it even more complicated how do we
perform an svm for this type of data set
here you can see we have a two
dimensional data set where the data is
in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and documents so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the regulation
parameter or lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be over fitted to
a very specific instance or is going to
be biased to a high or low value with
the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms these three
advantages of the support vector machine
make it a very powerful tool to add to
your repertoire of machine learning
tools now we did promise you a used case
study we're actually going to dive in to
some python programming and so we're
going to go into a problem statement and
start off with the zoo so in the zoo
example we have family members going to
the zoo we have the young child going
dead is that a group of crocodiles or
alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work especially
as a young child and so we can see the
parents sitting here thinking well what
is the difference between a crocodile
and an alligator well one crocodiles are
larger in size alligators are smaller in
size snout width the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout and of course in the modern day
and age the father is sitting here
thinking how can i turn this into a
lesson for my son and he goes let a
support vector machine segregate the two
groups i don't know if my dad ever told
me that but that would be funny now in
this example we're not going to use
actual measurements and data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up but let's
roll up our sleeves and we'll talk about
that more in just a moment as we break
into our python script so here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into a python editor in just a
moment but let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover first we're
going to cover in the code the setup how
to actually create our svm and you're
going to find that there's only two
lines of code that actually create it
and the rest of it is done so quick and
fast that it's all here in the first
page and we'll show you what that looks
like as far as our data because we're
going to create some data i talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blobs and we'll go through that
in just a second and then the second
part is we're going to take this and
we're going to bump it up a notch we're
going to show you what it looks like
behind the scenes but let's start with
actually creating our setup i like to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook
because it's very easy to use but you
can use any of your favorite python
editors or setups and go in there but
let's go ahead and switch over there and
see what that looks like so here we are
in the anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupiter notebook with python
we're using python 3. i believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and
you'd have to look at the sklearn and
make sure if you're using a 2x version
an earlier version let's go and put our
code in there and one of the things i
like about the jupiter notebook is i go
up to view and i'm going to go ahead and
toggle the line numbers on to make it a
little bit easier to talk about and we
can even increase the size because this
is edited in this case i'm using google
chrome explorer and that's how it opens
up for the editor although anyone any
like i said any editor will work now the
first step is going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as np and matplot library dot pi plot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python we need that
because part of the platform we're using
uses that for the numpy array and i'll
talk about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus the standard python array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use np for numpy the map plot library
is how we're going to view our data so
this has
you do need the np for the sklearn
module but the map plot library is
purely for our use for visualization and
so you really don't need that for the
svm but we're gonna put it there so you
have a nice visual aid and we can show
you what it looks like that's really
important at the end when you finish
everything so you have a nice display
for everybody to look at and then
finally we're gonna i'm gonna jump one
ahead to line number four that's the
sklearn.dataset
import make blobs and i told you that we
were going to make up data and this is a
tool that's in the sk learning and
makeup data i personally don't want to
go to the zoo get in trouble for jumping
over the fence and probably get eaten by
the crocodiles or alligators as i work
on measuring their snouts and width and
length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your setup and you're not sure
about what data you're going to put in
there you can create this blob and it
makes it real easy to use and finally we
have our actual svm the sklearn import
svm on line three so that covers all our
imports we're going to create remember i
use the make blobs to create data and
we're going to create a capital x and a
lowercase y equals make blobs in samples
equals 40. so we're going to make 40
lines of data it's going to have two
centers with a random state equals 20.
so which each each group is going to
have 20 different pieces of data in it
and the way that looks is that we'll
have under x
an x y plane so i have two numbers under
x and y will be 0 1 that's the two
different centers so we have yes or no
in this case alligator or crocodile
that's what that represents and then i
told you that the actual sk learner the
svm is in two lines of code and we see
it right here with clf equals svm dot
svc kernel equals linear and i set
sequel to one although in this example
since we are not regularizing the data
because we want to be very clear and
easy to see i went ahead you can set it
to a thousand a lot of times when you're
not doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
will be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit x comma y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and i'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish on the other side
that's our two sets of data they
represent one represents crocodiles and
one represents alligators and then we
have our measurements in this case we
have like the width and length of the
snout and i did say i was going to come
up here and talk just a little bit about
our plot and you'll see plt that's what
we imported we're going to do a scatter
plot that means we're just putting dots
on there and then look at this notation
i have the capital x and then in
brackets i have a colon comma 0. that's
from numpy if you did that in a regular
array you'll get an error in a python
array you have to have that in a numpy
array it turns out that our makeblobs
returns a numpy array and this notation
is great because what it means is the
first part is the colon means we're
going to do all the rows that's all the
data in our blob we created under
capital x and then the second part has a
comma 0. we're only going to take the
first value and then if you notice we do
the same thing but we're going to take
the second value remember we always
start with zero and then one so we have
column zero and column one and you can
look at this as our x y plots the first
one is the x plot and the second one is
the y plot so the first one is on the
bottom zero two four six 8 and 10 and
then the second one x of the one is the
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 going up the left hand
side s equals 30 is just the size of the
dots we can see them and said little
tiny dots and then the c map equals
plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
uh fit was done in two lines of code a
lot of times will be a third line where
we regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case i am giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width and length 5 6
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets and then i have the brackets
inside and the reason i do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case i'm processing two lines and
then i'm just going to print and you'll
see clf dot predict new data so the clf
and the dot predict part is going to
give us an answer and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see 0 1. so
predicted the first one the 3 4 is going
to be on the one side and the 5 6 is
going to be on the other side so one
came out as an alligator and one came
out as a crocodile now that's pretty
short explanation for the setup but
really we want to dug in and see what
it's going on behind the scenes and
let's see what that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph we're going to spend more
work on this and we did actually
generating the original model and you'll
see here that we go through a few steps
and i'll move this over to our editor in
just a second we come in we create our
original data it's exactly identical to
the first part and i'll explain why we
redid that and show you how not to redo
that and then we're going to go in there
and add in those lines we're going to
see what those lines look like and how
to set those up and finally we're going
to plot all that on here and show it and
you'll get a nice graph with the what we
saw earlier when we were going through
the theory behind this where it shows
the support vectors and the hyperplane
and those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 has plot show
and we're going to talk about that here
in just a second but let's scroll down
to a new line down here and i'm going to
paste that code in and you'll see that
the plot show has moved down below let's
scroll up a little bit and if you look
at the top here of our new section 1 2 3
and 4 is the same code we had before and
let's go back up here and take a look at
that we're going to fit the values on
our svm and then we're going to plot
scatter it and then we're going to do a
plot show so you should be asking why
are we redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here okay so this is how we
display a nice graph with our results in
our data ax is very standard note used
variable when you talk about plt and
it's just setting it to that axis the
last axis in the plt it can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable xx equal
to np.line space x limit 0 x limit 1
comma 30 and we've done the same thing
for the y space and then we're going to
go in here and we create a mesh grid and
this is a numpy command so we're back to
our numbers python let's go through what
these numpy commands mean with the line
space and the mesh grid we've taken x x
small s x x equals n p line space and we
have our x limit 0 and our x limit 1 and
we're going to create 30 points on it
and we're going to do the same thing for
the y axis now this has nothing to do
with our evaluation it's all we're doing
is we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between 0
and the x limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the y and then
the mesh grid loops those all together
so it forms a nice grit so if we were
going to do this say between the limit 0
and 10 and do 10 points we would have a
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on
you can just imagine a point at each
corner one of those boxes and the mesh
grid combines them all so we take the yy
and the xx we created and creates the
full grid and we've set that grid into
the y y coordinates and the x x
coordinates now remember we're working
with numbi and python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being x comma 1 you know x comma y
and then x2 comma y2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital yy and a
column of x's capital xx with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array x y array now that we've
created the stack of data points
we're going to do something interesting
here we're going to create a value z and
the z equals the clf that's our that's
our support vector machine we created
and we've already trained and we have a
dot decision function we're going to put
the x y in there so here we have all
this data we're going to put that x y in
there that data and we're going to
reshape it and you'll see that we have
the x x dot shape in here this literally
takes the xx resets it up connected to
the y and the z value lets us know
whether it is the left hand side is
going to generate three different values
the z value does and it'll tell us
whether that data is a support vector to
the left the hyperplane in the middle or
the support vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so it's
900 points of data and we separated
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot library we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
contour capital xx capital yy these have
been reshaped to fit those lines z is
the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have three levels of data
the alphas just makes it kind of see
through so it's only 0.5 of the value in
there so when we graph it the data will
show up from behind it wherever the
lines go and finally the line styles
this is where we set the two support
vectors to be dash dash lines and then a
single one is just a straight line
that's what all that setup does and then
finally we take our ax dot scatter we're
going to go ahead and plot the support
vectors but we've programmed it in there
so that they look nice like the dash
dash line and the dashed line on that
grid and you can see here when we do the
clf dot support vectors we are looking
at column zero and column one and then
again we have the s equals 100 so we're
going to make them larger and the line
width equals one face colors equals none
let's take a look and see what that
looks like when we show it and you can
see we get down to our end result it
creates a really nice graph we have our
two support vectors and dashed lines and
they have the near data so you can see
those two points or in this case the
four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in-depth today we're
going to cover the k nearest neighbors
like referred to as k n n and k n is
really a fundamental place to start in
the machine learning it's the basis of a
lot of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use knn
how does knn algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there
watching the black cat cross their path
no deer you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp brother claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
a question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now
unless they live a place where there's
not many cats or dogs so if we look at
the sharpness of the claws the length of
the ears and we can see that the cat has
smaller ears and sharper claws than the
other animals its features are more like
cats it must be a cat
sharp claws length of ears and goes in
the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat he classifies a data point
based on how his neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what what's the value we put in
there so we're going to talk about it
how do we choose a factor k k n
algorithm is based on feature similarity
choosing the right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to three we're going to
look at the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals a 7 we classify as a
triangle depending on what the other
data is around and you can see as the k
changes depending on where that point is
that drastically changes your answer and
we jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get it's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using uh like in
this case squares and triangles if it's
even you want to make your k value odd
that helps it select better so in other
words you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use knn when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in this says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what you know we're just voting
normal normal normal three votes for
normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knn positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the k n
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments like create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can use a simple
pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case i'm going to
it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see have a
number of windows open up at the top the
one we're working in and since we're
working on the k n predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and i'm
also going to go up here and click on
cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then i'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
i'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run as python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports we're going to import
the pandas as pd import numpy is np
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our train test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take and get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so that they're
all uniform between minus one and one
and then the actual tool this is the k
neighbors classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so that we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set in
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set 1 head data set 2 head
it only prints out the last one so i
used always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the nan
numpy nan is what that stands for is
none it doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here is we're replacing the
zero with a numpy none there's no data
there that's what that says that's what
this is saying right here so put the
zero in and we're going to place zeros
with no data so if it's a 0 that means
the person's well hopefully not dead
hope they just didn't get the data the
next thing we want to do is we're going
to create the mean which is the integer
from the data set from the column dot
mean where we skip n a's we can do that
that is a pandas command there the skip
n a so we're going to figure out the
mean of that data set and then we're
going to take that data set column and
we're going to replace all the n p n a n
with the means why did we do that and we
could have actually just uh taken this
step and gone right down here and just
replaced zero and skip anything were
except you could actually there's a way
to skip zeros and then just replace all
the zeros but in this case we want to go
ahead and do it this way so you can see
that we're switching this to a
non-existent value and we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see it skipped a bunch
in the middle that's what it does if you
have too many lines in jupiter notebook
it'll skip a few and go on to the next
in a data set let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
off the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we printed it
in here is outcome well that's not part
of the training data that's part of the
answer yes column nine but it's listed
as eight number eight so zero to eight
is nine columns so uh eight is the value
and when you see it in here zero this is
actually zero to seven it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the sklearn right
there and we simply put in our x and our
y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you see it i have to
look that up and then the test size test
size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 percent of the data and
put it aside so that we can test it
later that's all that is and again we're
going to run it not very exciting so far
we haven't had any printout other than
to look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is 1 to 6. we're going to set
that all so that all the data is between
-1 and 1. that's what that standard
scalar does keeps it standardized and we
only want to fit the scalar with the
training set but we want to make sure
the testing set is the x test going in
is also transformed so it's processing
it the same so here we go with our
standard scalar we're going to call it
sc underscore x for the scalar and we're
going to import the standard scalar into
this variable and then our x train
equals sc underscore x dot fit transform
so we're creating the scalar on the x
train variable and then our x test we're
also going to transform it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to go and run
this and if you look at this we've now
gone through these steps all three of
them we've taken care of replacing our
zeros for key columns that shouldn't be
zero and we replace that with the means
of those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we've scaled
the data so all of our data going in now
no we don't tr we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root let's do
y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11 so
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means value
there's all kinds of measure this but
the euclidean is the most common one and
it works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix y test
y predict so those are the two values
we're going to put in there and let me
go ahead and run that and print it out
and the way you interpret this is you
have the y predicted which would be your
title up here you could do uh let's just
do p r e d
predicted across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32 this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here in the column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero is a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct
but our prediction said another 15 out
of that 15 it classified as incorrect so
you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion matrix then we're going to go
ahead and print the f1 score let me just
run that and you see we get a 0.69 in
our f1 score
the f1
takes into account both sides of the
balance of false positives where if we
go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
tells us it is a pretty fair fit in the
model what is k-means clustering k-means
clustering is an unsupervised learning
algorithm in this case you don't have
labeled data unlike in supervised
learning so you have a set of data and
you want to group them and as the name
suggests you want to put them into
clusters which means objects that are
similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if k
is equal to two there will be two
clusters if k is equal to three three
clusters and so on and so forth that's
what the k stands for and of course
there is a way of finding out what is
the best or optimum value of k for a
given data we will look at that so that
is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about
the runs scored by the people ordered by
the player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and bowlers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is so there are information there
is information on the y-axis about the
run scored and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to two and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters
which means k is equal to two so two
points have been randomly assigned as
centroids keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from the centroid and the
distance from this center right this
point is taken and the distance is found
from this centroid and the center and so
on and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids
and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine the
central point or the actual centroid for
these two clusters so we have this one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of these new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is repeated the process of calculating
the distance and repositioning the
centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that the
algorithm has converged and we have the
final cluster with the data points and
the centroids so this is what you're
going to learn from this session we will
talk about the types of clustering what
is k-means clustering application of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
done using distance measure so we will
talk about the common distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b c d e f we start by
combining b and c from one cluster d e
and e form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add bc to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into
successively smaller clusters so we have
abcdef we first take that as a single
cluster and then break it down
into a b c d
e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k-means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics are compared and all
objects having similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done we will see it
in more detail as we move forward and
fuzzy c means is very similar to k means
in the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
systems search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells
how similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have square
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure it's nothing but the
square of the euclidean distance as the
name suggests so instead of taking the
square root
we leave the square as it is and then we
have manhattan distance measure in case
of manhattan distance it is the sum of
the distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k means now let's go and
check how exactly k k-means clustering
works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of k what
should be the best value of k how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of k we specify that and
then the system will assign that many
centroids so it picks randomly that to
start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss
that is taken as the optimum value of k
so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x-axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to one which means all
the data points are in a single cluster
the witnesses value will be very high
because they are probably scattered all
over the moment you split it into two
there will be a drastic fall in the
within ss value that's what is
represented here but then as the value
of k increases the decrease the rate of
decrease will not be so high it will
continue to decrease but probably the
rate of decrease will not be high so
that gives us an idea so from here we
get an idea for example the optimum
value of k should be either 2 or 3 or at
the most 4 but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two
centroids randomly so let's say c1 and
c2 are the centroids assigned randomly
now the distance of each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned to them but now in this step
the actual centroid will be calculated
which may be for each of these data sets
somewhere in the middle so that's like
the main point that will be calculated
and the centroid will actually be
positioned or repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned
and again the centroid will be
calculated and if the centroid doesn't
change so that is the repetitive process
iterative process and if the centroid
doesn't change once the centroid stops
changing that means the algorithm has
converged and this is our final cluster
with this as the centroid c1 and c2 as
the centroids these data points as a
part of each cluster so i hope this
helps in understanding the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first
round of assignment that is done now we
have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we pick the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups
which is like the mean position which
means that the position of the randomly
selected centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of these newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two
and three so we again calculate the
distance of x1
from
the centroid c1 c2 c3 and then c which
is the lowest value and assign x1 to
that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence
so let's take a detailed look at it at
each of these steps so we randomly pick
k cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2
x2 from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two
we now have all the points all the data
points
grouped into k groups because we we
wanted to create k clusters right so we
have k groups each one may be having a
certain number of input values and they
need not be equally distributed by the
way based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step 3
we actually calculate the centroid of
each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through
three or four or five times
the centroid will stop moving in the
sense that when you calculate the new
value of the centroid that will be same
as the original value or there will be
very marginal change so that is when we
say convergence has occurred and that is
our final cluster that's the formation
of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in python notebook
using pattern notebook but before that
let's find out what's the problem that
we are trying to solve the problem
statement is let's say walmart wants to
open a chain of stores across the state
of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant they already have
the addresses of their customers in
their database so they can actually use
this information or this data and use
k-means clustering to find the optimal
location
now before we go into the python
notebook and show you the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see
how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct
groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual
k-means clustering process
so we will assign each of these points
to the centroids and then check whether
they are the optimal distance which is
the shortest distance and assign each of
the points data points to the centroids
and then go through this iterative
process till the whole process converges
and finally we get an output like this
so we have four distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and
these centroids are
like the location where the store should
be the optimum location where the store
should be so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help walmart find the
best locations for their stores in
florida so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are learning
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupiter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how
k-means clustering is used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well okay so let's
get started okay so this block is
basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify how many clusters we want
so centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually
provides
now from here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality of the
function is readily available
you just need to feed the data and will
create the clusters
so this is the code for that
we import k-means and then
we create an instance of k-means and we
specify the value of k this n underscore
clusters is the value of k remember k
means in k means k is basically the
number of clusters that you want to
create and it is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as
with any other machine learning
functionality fit is what we use the
function or the method rather fit is
what we use to train the model here
there is no real training kind of thing
but that's the call okay so we are
calling fit and what we are doing here
we are just passing the data so x has
these values the data that has been
created right so that is what we are
passing here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters
and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which uh basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster one
this is 2 3 and so on or i will actually
start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and 3 maybe
and then for each of the observations it
will assign based on which cluster it
belongs to it will assign a value so
that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these uh
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have how many about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here
each of them the cluster number is given
and the cluster number goes from 0 to 3
so there are 4 clusters so the numbers
go from 0 1 2 3. so that's what is seen
here ok now so this was a quick example
of generating some dummy data and then
clustering that okay and this can be
applied if you have proper data you can
just load it up into x for example here
and then run the game so this is the
central part of the k-means clustering
program example so you basically create
an instance and you mention how many
clusters you want by specifying this
parameter and underscore clusters and
that is also the value of k and then
pass the data to get the values now the
next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code
at each step what it is doing and then
we will see a couple of more examples of
how k-means clustering
can be used in maybe some real-life
examples real-life use cases all right
so in this case here what we are doing
is basically implementing the k means
clustering and there is a function or a
library calculates for a given two pairs
of points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign the
data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position which is the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is uh done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case also with
that is actually convergence right so
for example the change is 0.0001 we can
consider that as convergence otherwise
what will happen is this will either
take forever or it will be never ending
so that's a small flaw here so that is
something additional checks may have to
be added here but again as mentioned
this is not the most sophisticated
implementation uh this is like a kind of
a rough implementation of the k-means
clustering okay so if we execute this
code this is what we get as the output
so this is the definition of this
particular function and then we call
that find underscore clusters and we
pass our data x and the number of
clusters which is four
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of an implementation of k-means
clustering
and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used in maybe some real-life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory so that is the
scenario where something like this can
be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm and this
will then create clusters of only 16
clusters so this this colors there are
millions of colors and now we need to
bring it down to 16 colors so we use k
is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 color so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though the image quality is definitely
reduced a little bit
so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node and once again as always we
will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let we load that
and this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and this is the shape of
this image which is basically what is
the
shape is nothing but the overall size
right so this is 427 pixel by 640 pixel
and then there are three layers which is
this three basically is for rgb which is
red green blue so color image will have
that right so that is the shape of this
now what we need to do is data let's
take a look at how data is looking so
let me just create a new cell and show
you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china
and if we see here this is how the data
is stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix
and each one has about for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are
large the numbers are large so we need
to normalize them to between zero and
one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between zero and 1 and the way to do
that is divide by 255 so we divide china
by 255 and we get the new values in data
so let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just
insert uh probably a cell here
and take a look at how data is looking
all right so this is how data is looking
and now you see this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between 0 and 1. this
is one of the things we need to do
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k-means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are these this is
how the 16 colors
would look
so this is red against green and this is
red against blue there is uh quite a bit
of similarity between this original
color schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look very very completely
different or anything like that now we
apply this the newly created colors to
the image
and we can take a look how this is
looking now we can compare both the
images so this is our original image and
this is our new image so as you can see
there is not a lot of information that
has been lost it pretty much looks like
the original image yes we can see that
for example here there is a little bit
uh it appears a little dullish compared
to this one right because we kind of
took off some of the finer details of
the color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k means clustering
and we do the same process like before
we reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16
and then we render the image once again
and we will see that the color the
quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so this is
the image now once again we can take a
look at the shape which is 427 by 640 by
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much big so we will
much bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
does the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for with
the new just the 16 color so once again
as you can see this looks much richer in
color but at the same time and this
probably doesn't have as we can see it
doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably not that
sophisticated okay so that's pretty much
it so we have seen two examples of how
color compression can be done using
k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering hey everyone welcome to this
live session by simply learn in today's
session we will take you through the
most debated topic that has taken the
world by storm yes you guessed it right
we are talking about coronavirus but
before we proceed make sure to subscribe
to our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update in this session we
will learn about what coronavirus really
is how did it emerge and what are its
symptoms then we will see what has been
its impact so far in terms of the total
cases emerging the total number of
deaths reported and the total number of
recoveries across the globe we will
analyze the outbreak of coronavirus
across different regions visualize them
using charts and graphs and predict the
number of upcoming confirmed cases for
the next 10 days that is between the
16th of march to the 25th of march using
linear regression model and support
vector machines in python finally we'll
look at the various safety measures that
you can take to save yourself from
getting attacked by coronavirus
before we begin let me clarify that this
video majorly focuses on how you can use
machine learning algorithms to make
predictions on such sensitive issues we
will certainly cover the current
scenario and the impact it has created
worldwide but there is nothing to panic
at all make sure you take all the
necessary precautions to stay safe also
the predictions may vary from the
current situation that you see as the
data was taken from kegel that may have
some variations
this is only to make you learn how you
can perform analysis on such data sets
and derive insights from the prediction
so let's start with what is coronavirus
coronaviruses first discovered in 1960s
are a family of viruses that cause
illness ranging from common cold to
severe diseases such as middle east
respiratory syndrome and severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronaviruses can
be transmitted between animals and human
beings and hence they are zoonotic
now let's see how coronavirus emerged in
december 2019 the city of wuhan in dubai
province which is china's seventh
largest city comprising 11 million
residents became the center of a
pneumonia outbreak of unknown cause the
chinese health authorities conducted an
immediate investigation of these cases
to identify and control its spread by
isolating suspected patients closely
monitoring their contacts and obtaining
detailed clinical and epidemiologic data
the source of coronavirus 2019 or covet
19 is believed to be a wet market in
wuhan
which sold both dead and live animals
including fish and birds
let's see the symptoms of coronavirus
kovite 19 is characterized by symptoms
such as cold cough running nose sore
throat and fever illness can be more
severe for some people and can lead to
pneumonia or breathing difficulties
older people and people with other
medical conditions such as asthma
diabetes or heart disease may be more
vulnerable to becoming severely ill the
noble corona virus is now a public
health emergency of international
concern
people across the globe are racing to
cut short their vacations and rebook
flights home
as most countries continue to lock down
cities and towns amid the spread of
coronavirus as per the world health
organization till the 15th of march the
total deaths reported globally stood at
while more than 100 000 people were
infected worldwide on the 11th of march
the world health organization declared
coveted 19 as pandemic
on the screen you can see the total
coronavirus cases till the 13th of march
across the globe
most of the countries have been affected
by the spread of coronavirus
china south korea iran italy france
spain and germany are some of the
countries that got hit the most
next you see china italy iran and the
united states of america have the
highest number of deaths reported till
the 13th of march the next map shows you
the total recovered cases across
different parts of the world china italy
iran and south korea have the most
number of patients who have recovered
now
let's move on to the most important part
of this video where we will analyze the
outbreak of coronavirus cases across
different countries and visualize them
using different charts and graphs the
data has information from the 22nd of
january till the 15th of march using
this data we will predict the upcoming
cases for the next 10 days using
algorithms such as linear regression and
support vector machines in python now
let me go ahead and show you the data
sets that we will be using for this
analysis
so for this analysis we'll be using
three csv files
so here you can see we i have opened all
the three files the first data set is
regarding the confirmed cases it has
columns such as province of the state
country or the region
latitude longitude
and the number of confirmed cases that
came up in all these days
similarly
the second data set is regarding
the deaths of patients
between 22nd of jan till the 15th of
march
and the third data set is regarding the
number of recovered cases
during the same time interval
now
let's start with understanding the code
for this demo where we will use support
vector machine and linear regression to
build our model and predict the total
number of confirmed cases that may come
up in the next 10 days again to clarify
our prediction may vary from the current
scenario that you actually see since
this data set was taken from kegel which
is usually for learning purposes i have
already implemented the code on jupyter
notebook i'll run through each cell of
code and explain to you what it does
first
we will import all the necessary
libraries that are important for this
analysis as you can see
we are importing libraries such as numpy
and pandas that are used for numerical
computations and manipulations then i am
importing matplotlib library for
visualizing the data and the model
followed by math and time
after that from the skllen library i am
importing certain functions such as
train test split
svr to build the model
and so on we are also using matrix
functions such as mean squared error and
main absolute error and so on
now let me run this cell by hitting
shift plus enter
we have successfully run that cell
now we will load all the three data sets
one by one for that i have used the
pandas library and read underscore csv
function
which you can see here
i have provided the location of the file
followed by the file name and the
extension of the file which is dot csv
i've loaded all the three data sets into
three variable names now let me run all
the three cells to import all the three
data sets
i'll hit shift enter
scroll down
we'll load the deaths
data set and the recovered data set
now to display the data sets i'm using
dot head function to see the top five
rows from the data
you can see the top five rows from the
confirmed underscore cases data set
similarly
you can check the top five rows from the
reported data set
from the depths reported data set
and from the recovered cases as well
after that
i am extracting all the column names
from the confirmed cases data frame
using the dot keys function
let me run it
so below you can see
all the columns been displayed
then we are extracting only the date
columns that have information of
confirmed cases death cases and
recovered cases using the dot loc
function
the first parameter that is colon tells
you we need all the rows
while the second parameter
tells you that we need data from the
fourth column till the last column which
are the date values
now let me run all the three
you can go ahead to see the outbreak
cases using confirmed dot head
here you can see it has only the date
columns and the values for each of the
dates
after that in the next cell i am finding
the total confirmed cases death cases
and the recovered cases and appending
them to four empty lists
we are also calculating the total
mortality rate which is nothing but the
total death sum divided by the total
confirmed cases
you can see
i have declared four empty lists namely
world cases
total debts mortality rate and total
recover
then
i'm running a for loop
taking the date variables into
consideration so for each of the date
values
we are summing the total confirmed cases
the death cases and the recoveries
after that i am appending the values to
the four empty lists that we had created
now let me run it
moving ahead let me display each of the
newly created variables one by one
so if i run confirmed underscore sum you
can see the total number of confirmed
cases
which is nearly 1 lakh 67 449.
now if i run this one it will tell you
the total number of debts that have been
reported which is 6440
and the total number of recoveries stand
at 76.34
similarly if i run world cases
you can see
this kind of an array
which have been listed date wise
in the next step i am converting all the
dates and the cases in the form of a
numpy array using np dot array function
let me run it
now i can display all the newly created
arrays by passing the variable names
so if i run days since 22nd of jan
you can see it will list you the total
number of days that were present from
the 22nd of jan till the 15th of march
now if i run world cases you can see it
has an array
which has values of the total number of
cases that emerge between
22nd of march
till
the 15th of march
similarly
if i run the total debts variable
you can see it lists all the death
values between 22nd of jan till
15th of march
and finally for the total recovered
cases
now since our prediction will be for the
next 10 days
so i have created a variable called days
in future
and assigned a value of 10.
then i am adding the last 10 days to the
total number of days we have now let me
show you the value of future forecast by
running the cell
you can see below
future forecast
has given us a total of
64 days
next we are converting all the integers
into date time values for better
visualization
so let's run it
now before we start building our code
let's visualize the data using different
charts and graphs and see what has been
the impact of coronavirus so far
for visualization we need the latest
data of 15th of march
so i have extracted the last column
values for all the three data sets
now let me display these for you
i'll run latest underscore confirmed
you can see it gives you all the values
from the 15th of march
similarly i'll go ahead and run the
remaining
latest deaths gives you
the total debts that were reported on
15th of march
across various regions
similarly
for the latest recoveries as well
after that i am finding the list of
unique countries using the dot unique
function
if i run this
so below you can see there are different
countries
so that's thailand japan singapore
malaysia
all the countries across the globe
so in the next cell
i'm basically calculating the total
number of confirmed cases by each
country so i have created two empty
lists
namely country confirmed cases and no
cases
if the cases are greater than zero i am
appending the values to country
confirmed cases else i am appending it
to no cases
next i am finding the number of cases
per country or region
so you can see that china has the
highest number of cases
followed by italy and iran
now in this cell of code we are finding
the list of unique provinces using the
dot unique function again
now there are certain countries that
have been marked as provinces of states
such as the united kingdom denmark and
france
those we are classifying as outliers and
removing them from the list
next we are finding the number of
confirmed cases per province state or
city so for this
we have created two empty lists namely
province confirmed cases and no cases if
the cases are greater than zero i am
appending them to province confirmed
cases else to no cases i am also
removing the areas with no confirmed
cases
now you can see the total number of
cases per province city or state
so here are the values coming to the
next cell
in this piece of code
you're basically handling nan
or missing values
let me just run it
okay
so now that we have done with preparing
the data for visualization
let's build different charts and graphs
to see what we can derive from it
first we'll plot a bar graph to see the
total confirmed cases across different
countries in the beginning
i am giving the size of the graph using
plt dot figure so we have 32 by 32 size
then i am passing the unique countries
in the x axis and the country confirmed
cases in the y axis
i have given a title to this graph
number of coveted 19 confirmed cases in
countries i have also given a label for
the x-axis which is number of
covet-confirmed cases we are using
plt.show that will display the graph
let me run it
as you can see if i scroll down
china
has the highest number of cases followed
by italy iran south korea spain germany
france and so on
now i'll plot another bar graph to see
the total confirmed cases between
mainland china and outside mainland
china
for mainland china i am finding the sum
of all the cases where country or region
equal to equal to china
while for outside mainland china i am
taking the sum of all the confirmed
cases and subtracting china cases
let me now run it
as you can see the total number of cases
outside china is more than mainland
china
now if you want you can also print the
exact values which i have done below
so the total cases outside mainland
china
is around 86
446 while in china it is close to 81 000
and the overall cases till 15th of march
stand at 1 lakh 67
449 another thing i have done is to show
10 countries that have the most number
of confirmed cases while the rest of the
countries have grouped into a category
named others
so i have created two empty lists
named visual unique countries and visual
confirmed cases i have taken the 10
countries based on the top 10 cases
while the others category has the
remaining cases
now let's visualize the 10 countries
using a bar graph
so this is how the graph looks like
on the y-axis you have the different
country names you also have
the others category
and on the x axis
you have the number of cases
you can see
china has the highest number of covet 19
cases italy has the second highest while
other countries in total
have the third highest cases
now the same visualization you can do
using a pie chart to check the total
confirmed cases in 10 different
countries
i have used a color scheme css 4 colors
i have given the figure size 20 by 20
i am using plt.pi function and
plt.legend function to show the
different countries
let me just run it
so here is how
the pie chart looks like
and to the right you can see the
different legends
so this color corresponds to china
while this one corresponds to italy
this is actually others and so on
here i have created another pie chart to
visualize the total confirmed cases in
10 different countries apart from china
it has the same code as ever
but
under plt.pie i have passed columns
apart from china and hence we are using
one colon similarly under plt.legend we
have values apart from china
let me run it
so this is how the pie chart looks like
as you can see italy has the highest
number of cases followed by iran and
then south korea
we also have others in this category
which has
pretty high number of confirmed cases
so now that we have visualized our data
let's start by building our model using
a support vector machine algorithm
support vector machine uses different
parameters to build a model these
parameters are kernel c
gamma epsilon shrinking and svm grid
kernel specifies the kernel type to be
used in the algorithm it must be one of
linear poly rbf sigmoid precomputed or
callable if nothing is given rbf will be
used c is a regularization parameter
gamma is the kernel coefficient of rbf
poly and sigmoid epsilon specifies the
epsilon tube within which no penalty is
associated in the training loss function
shrinking takes boolean values that is
true or false
svm grid has all the values passed as
parameters to it
then
with the help of randomized search cv
function we are building a model by
passing the necessary parameters finally
we are fitting the data using svm search
dot fit function and passing
xtrain confirmed and y train confirmed
let me now run it
this might take some time
since we have an epoch or an iteration
defined
here we have given 40 iterations
now we have successfully run that
particular cell
now
let's find the best parameters for the
model
so you can see the result shrinking is
false
kernel it has taken as poly gamma's
value is 0.1
epsilon value is 0.01 and c value is
also 0.01
now you can find the best estimator
using svm search dot best estimator
function
and predict the future forecast using
the predict function i'll run this
if i run svm underscore confirmed below
you can see the results
similarly svm underscore predict will
tell you
the predicted values
for all the dates
now you can check the values of the
testing data after creating the model
for that we'll create a plot with the
svm test predicted data and the y test
confirm data
then i'll print the mean absolute error
and the mean squared error values
so below you can see the graph and the
error values
then i'll plot the total number of
coronavirus cases over time starting
from 22nd of jan
i have given a title number of
coronavirus cases over time
so there are x labels and y labels
defined
let me now run it
so here is the graph
on the y axis you can see the number of
cases and on the x axis you can see the
total number of days by looking at the
graph you can tell after 40 days
the cases were close to 90 000 and now
after 50 plus days the cases have
reached nearly one lakh sixty thousand
the next plot shows you the total
confirmed cases versus the svm predicted
cases that might come up
let me now run it
here you can see the graph
the blue line which is this one
it represents all the confirmed cases
while the dotted purple line is the
prediction from the svm model
which is this one
now we'll predict the values of the
cases for the next 10 days using the svm
algorithm
here is the output
you can see it starts from the 16th of
march till the 25th of march that is the
next 10 days after 15th of march you can
see the total number of upcoming cases
each day
so on 16th of march the model predicts
there will be around 1 lakh 84 000 cases
on 17th of march we might have one lakh
93 000 cases and so on
let us now see how you can predict these
cases using the linear regression model
so
we have imported the linear regression
function from the scikit-learn library
i have fit the model with x train and
white rain confirmed data which is this
one
for prediction i have used x test
confirmed data and the future forecast
data
finally in the end i am printing the
values of ma and msc for this model let
me now go ahead and run this code
below you can see it has given us the
value for mean absolute error and mean
squared error
let's now plot the confirmed values from
the test data and the linear predicted
data
so this is how the graph looks like
like we did for the svm model we can
also plot a graph to show the number of
coronavirus cases over time since 22nd
of jan
i'll run this
so here is the graph
the blue line depicts the confirmed
cases while the yellow line tells the
linear regression predictions
now i'll go ahead and predict the cases
for the next 10 days using linear
regression here you can see the
predictions
it is different from that of the sva
model which had a higher number of cases
now we'll plot the total number of
deaths over time
let me run it
so as you can see from the graph
on the x axis we have time that is the
number of days on the y axis we have the
number of deaths
so by day 50
the number of deaths reported have
crossed 5000.
in the next cell we are plotting a graph
to visualize the total mortality rate of
coronavirus cases over time
i'll hit shift enter
so here is the graph of mortality rate
of coronavirus cases over time
then i am plotting the total number of
coronavirus cases recovered over time
as you can see from the graph
nearly 75 000 people have recovered from
this pandemic
in the next plot
i am checking the number of coronavirus
cases based on deaths and recoveries
so below is how the graph looks like
the green line represents the number of
recoveries
and the red line represents the number
of deaths
as you can see there are a lot of
recovered cases which is good news
and finally we are checking the total
number of coronavirus deaths versus
recoveries in a single plot
so here is the graph
the x-axis has the number of recoveries
while the y-axis has the number of
deaths reported so far
with that we have come to the end of the
demo to analyze coronavirus outbreak
globally
now let me address a few questions that
our viewers are asking related to
coronavirus and about this prediction
analysis first question i can see here
is how coronavirus spreads and how to
protect yourself
so coronavirus spreads in a similar way
to flu or the common cold
basically in large droplets produced by
curves or sneezes germs can leave on
surfaces for several hours
public health england defines the spread
as having close contact with a virus
carrier within 2 meters of the person
for 15 minutes
as mentioned there is no vaccine as of
now to protect yourself you need to take
precautionary measures such as regularly
washing your hands staying away from
crowded places like malls and pubs and
using masks
another question which i can see on the
chat window is who started the
coronavirus to be honest there are a
number of crazy conspiracy theories that
have been circulating that the virus
somehow escaped from a chinese lab
either by accident or design however
this is categorically untrue and
scientists studying its genetic code
have linked it to bats it probably then
jumped to other animals which passed it
on to humans
one more question is can we use time
series analysis and other type of
algorithms to make predictions of the
cases of course you can you can use time
series analysis to predict the upcoming
cases
but it would be recommended for you to
have individual data from different
countries you can also use algorithms
such as bayesian ridge and logistic
regression there's another question can
we also predict the death cases and the
recovered cases for the next 10 days
surely you can predict both the
parameters you just need to provide the
total debts and the total recovered
cases information to the splitting step
where we are dividing the data set
with that i think we have covered most
of the important questions related to
this topic
machine learning is the future and yours
can begin today comment below with your
email id to get our latest machine
learning career guide let your journey
begin
finally it's our duty to tell you the
important safety precautions that you
can take to ensure you are not suffering
from the spread of coronavirus since
there is no coronavirus vaccine yet so
here are the measures that you can
follow clean your hands often with soaps
and sanitizers avoid close contact with
people who are ill
always wear a face mask when you are out
practice respiratory hygiene
please avoid gathering in crowded places
do stay at home if you are sick and most
importantly seek medical care early if
you have fever cough or difficulty
breathing
and with that we have reached the end of
this session
welcome to another live session by
simplyloan
i would like to thank you all for
actively participating in these sessions
on youtube and facebook today we will
understand how to perform stock market
prediction using machine learning
so what really is stock market
a stock market is a place or a public
market where you can buy and sell shares
for publicly listed companies
the stocks which are also known as
equities represent ownership in the
company
the stock exchange is the mediator that
allows the buying and selling of shares
amsterdam stock exchange is the oldest
stock exchange that were established in
the top stock exchanges in the united
states are the new york stock exchange
nasdaq american stock exchange and
chicago board operations exchange
in india we have the bombay stock
exchange or the bsc that was established
in 1875 and it's asia's first stock
exchange
we also have the national stock exchange
or nse
now let's understand the importance of
stock market
stock markets help companies to raise
capital
if stock markets did not exist then
companies would have to resort to
borrowing loans from the banks to raise
money for expansion
this would be a trouble for the company
as they would have to repay the loans
with interest
with stock markets companies have the
free hand to create an initial public
offering and raise large amounts of cash
without having to worry about repayment
another reason why the stock market is
important is it helps generate personal
wealth for an individual investor the
stock market provides a platform to
invest your income and earn a share of
the company's profit
stock markets serve as an indicator of
the state of the economy
that is the stock market serves as a
barometer for the economy
a rise of fall in the prices of shares
indicates what cycle the economy is in
such as a recession or a boom
the stock market is considered to be one
of the most widely used sources for
people to invest money in
investors are always looking to invest
in companies with high growth potential
if the stock market is performing well
this increases investment from local
investors
it also attracts foreign direct
investment as people abroad invest in
the local stock exchange
with that
let's now understand stock market
prediction
stock market prediction helps you
determine the future value of company
stock and other financial instruments
traded on an exchange
the whole idea of predicting stock
prices is to gain significant profits
predicting how the stock market will
perform is a difficult task to do
there are a lot of other factors
involved in the predictions such as
physical and psychological factors
rational and irrational behavior etc
all these factors combined to make sure
prices dynamic and volatile
this makes it very difficult to predict
stock prices with high accuracy
so we will use machine learning
techniques to predict the stock prices
of two different companies tesla and
google
we'll be using linear regression
algorithm and long short term memory
networks for building our prediction
models
so first
let's understand the basics of linear
regression
linear regression is a very popular
statistical technique used for solving
machine learning problems
it is a supervised learning algorithm
for predicting the output of a
continuous target variable it can be
used to predict the total revenue of a
company or the total units expected to
be sold of a certain product
it can also be used for weather
prediction
and stock price prediction
now here is an example to predict the
total number of ice creams a vendor or a
company can sell based on the
temperature of the day
you can see the green dots represent the
actual data points
so the x axis has the input variable
that is temperature and the y-axis has
the target variable that is units sold
linear regression uses the linear
equation formula
y is equal to mx plus c
where m is the slope of the line
c is the intercept
we find the coefficients and plot the
regression line
so in this graph the red line is a
the best fit line should have the least
square distance between the original
data points and the predicted values
now let's see how to predict the stock
prices of tesla using the linear
regression model
so this is the csv data set that we will
be using for our prediction
we have information from the 29th of
june 2010
till the 15th of may 2019
here
open column means the price at which a
stock started trading when the market
opened on a particular day
the close column refers to the price of
an individual stock when the stock
exchange closed market for the day
it represents the last buy sell order
executed between two traders
the high column is the highest price at
which a stock traded during a period
the low
is the lowest price of the period
volume is the total amount of trading
activity during a period of time
the adjusted closing price is a
calculation adjustment
made to the stock's closing price
it is more complex and accurate than the
closing price
the adjustment made to the closing price
depicts the true price of the stock
because the outside factors could have
altered the true price
now before i begin the demo i want to
tell you that if you want to get a copy
of the source code files and the data
sets that i'll be using in this session
then please put your email ids in the
chat section of the video
also please subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to stay updated with
all the latest trending technologies
so here is my jupyter notebook where i
have implemented my linear regression
code
so i'll run through each cell of code
and explain what it does
first
we'll import the necessary libraries for
building our model
so i'm importing pandas numpy and
matplotlib for numerical computation
data manipulation and data visualization
we'll also import the plotly library for
building our graphs
now if you are using plotly for the
first time you will have to install it
and then import it onto jupiter
let me run this cell
so i have successfully imported all my
libraries
next
i load the tesla stock price data set
using the pandas library and the read
underscore csv function
i'll also give the location where my csv
data set is present
now let me import the data set i'll hit
shift enter
so now i have successfully imported my
data set
now let's
see my data sets for that i'll use the
head function
alloy tesla dot head
so this will return the top five rows
from the data set
in the next cell
i am using the info function to find the
total rows and columns in my data set
the info function will also return the
data type of the variables and check if
there are any null values
there you go
so we have total seven columns and there
are
2193 entries
here you can see the data type of each
column and each column has no null
values
moving ahead
in the next step we are converting the
date column into date time format using
pandas library and two underscore
datetime function
up next let's do some exploratory data
analysis and get more insights from our
data
i am using the print function and a
formatted string lateral that is f
these strings contain replacement fields
which are expressions delimited by curly
braces you can see here
here i am finding out the data frame
contains stock prices between what dates
and the total number of days
so the total number of days can be
calculated by subtracting the maximum
date value and the minimum date value
so let me go ahead and run it
you can see
our stock prices
are from 29th of june 2010
till 15th of march
2019 and the total number of days are
3181 days
now let's see some summary statistics
for our data using the describe function
so the describe function
gives you the count mean standard
deviation the maximum and minimum from
each column the 25th quartile the 50th
quartile and the 75th quartile
let me now go ahead and create a box
plot to visually check our outliers i am
considering five columns open high low
close and
adjusted close
so this is how our box plot looks like
in this cell
we'll plot a graph using the plotly
library that we have imported
we are setting the layout for our graph
using the go layout function
am providing a title to the graph
i am also setting my x-axis for giving
the title
so
the x-axis will have the date column you
can see it here
we are also defining the title font the
family
size and color
similarly i am providing the layout for
the y-axis
you can see it here
finally i am passing my data list
and the layout created to plot variable
let me go ahead and run it
now i'll plot my graph using the iplot
function
there you go so we have the stock prices
of tesla plotted in this graph
on x-axis we have the year
from 2011 to 2019
and on the y-axis you have the price
which is basically the
close column
you can see from the graph
that initially during 2011 or 2010
the stock prices were
growing a little lower than expected
but towards 2015 16 and
17 onwards the stock prices grew higher
now
coming to the most important part that
is to build the linear regression model
so in this cell i am importing the
necessary libraries and the respective
functions
first i am importing the train
underscore test underscore split
function from the scikit-learn library
next
i am also importing some pre-processing
functions like min max scalar and
standard scalar from sql library
also
for evaluating the model and finding the
accuracy we'll use the mean squared
error and r squared error from
scikit-learn matrix library
let me run it
so we have successfully imported our
required libraries
moving ahead
in the current step
we are splitting the data into training
and testing sets the x variable contains
the independent features and the y
variable has the dependent variable or
the target variable that is closed
column
i am taking the test data size as 0.3 or
30 percent of the total
and i am assigning a random state of one
zero one
let's run it
okay
now
i'll perform feature scaling on the
xtrain dataset
for that i am using the standard
scalar.fit function and passing in my
xtrain data
standardization of a dataset is a common
requirement for any machine learning
algorithm
they might behave badly if the
individual features are not normally
distributed
so that's why feature scaling is
important
with that
it's time for us to import the linear
regression function from the circuit
learn library
now
using a variable lm which stands for
linear model i'll declare a linear
regression function
and then i'll use the fit method to pass
the training data sets that is xtrine
and white drain
so let me run it
now we have successfully created a
linear regression model
next
we'll plot the graph for actual and
predicted values for the training data
set
here we'll be creating a scatter plot
and draw our prediction line
so i have used the go.scatter function
i am using
markers for plotting the actual data
points and i have used a line to draw
the prediction line
let me run it
now to plot the graph i use the iplot
function
if i scroll down
you can see
on the x-axis we have the day column
or the day variable
and on the y-axis we have the prices of
our stocks
the blue dots represent the actual stock
values if i hover over this blue dots
you can see the actual
values
and
the red line is a predicted
regression line
the final step will calculate the scores
for evaluating our model
so here we are using two matrix one is r
squared error and mean squared error
for finding the r squared error we have
used
r to underscore score function and i am
passing my
y train
as well as x train using the lm predict
function
similarly
for finding the r squared error for
testing data set i am using y test
and lm predict for
x test
likewise to find the mean squared error
value i have used the y train and ytest
data along with predicted xtrain and
extras data
now let me run it
below you can see the two matrix scores
so our r squared error score is around
0.86 for the training set and it's
around the same value of 0.86 for
testing data set and similarly you can
see the mean squared error as well
with that you saw how to predict the
tesla stock prices using linear
regression model in python
if you want to get a copy of the source
code files and the data sets that i am
using in this session then please put
your email ids in the chat section we'll
share the files over email
also please subscribe to our channel and
stay updated with all the latest
technologies
now we will understand about long
short-term memory networks
so lstms are a type of recurrent neural
networks for learning long term
dependencies
it is commonly used for processing and
predicting on the basis of time series
data
from the image on the left you can see
lstms have a chain like structure
instead of having a single neural
network layer
there are four interacting layers
communicating with each other in a very
special way
now lstms work in a three-step process
the first step in lstm is to decide
which information to be omitted from the
cell in that particular time step
it is decided by the help of a sigmoid
function
it looks at the previous state that is h
t minus 1 and the current input state
that is x t and computes the function
in the second layer there are two parts
one is the sigmoid function and the
other is the tan h function
or the hyperbolic tangent function in
the sigmoid function
it decides which values to let through
that is 0 or 1
the hyperbolic tangent function gives
the weightage to the values which are
passed deciding their level of
importance from -1 to plus 1.
in the third step
it decides what will be your final
output
first it will run a sigmoid layer which
decides which parts of the cell state
make it to the output
then
we put the cell state through the 10h
function to push the values to be
between minus 1 and plus 1
and multiply it by the output of the
sigmoid gate
now let's go to our jupyter notebook and
implement a long short-term memory
network to predict the stock prices of
google
before that let me first show you the
data set that we will be using
so this is my jupyter lab
and on the left you can see we have our
google data sets
so we will be using two data sets for
this demo a training data set and a
testing data set
let me show you how the training data
set looks like
i'll open
a csv
table so this is our training data set
of google
it has the same columns like date open
high low close and volume
and if i scroll down you can see
we have data from 2012 till 2016.
let me close this
now let me open my google test data set
so this is my test data set
and
we'll be using this data set to evaluate
our model
so first
let me go ahead and import all the
libraries that we'll be needing to build
our lstm model
you can see
i'm importing the numpy pandas and
matplotlib library for numerical
computation data manipulation and data
visualization
we are also importing min max scalar
function from scikit-learn
pre-processing library
then we have some built-in functions
from the keras library
such as sequential to analyze a sequence
of data then dense lstm and dropout to
measure the dropout rate
i'll hit shift enter to run this cell
you can see it says we are using
tensorflow
backend
now
let me go ahead and import the google
training data set using
read underscore csv function from pandas
i have imported my data set now if you
want to check the head of the data set
you can use data dot head
run again so it will display the top
five rows from the data set
similarly
now let's see the total rows and columns
we have in this data set and the data
types of each variable
we'll use the info function for this
you can see
this is my output
so we have a total of 6 columns and
1258 entries
and here you can see the data type so
date it has taken as object
open it has taken as float
high it has taken as float similarly
close and volume column it has taken as
object
now we will do some pre-processing of
data to transform our closing price
variable to a numeric type
drop the non-available data and keep
only the close column for training the
data
now to convert the close column into
numeric i have used pd dot
2 underscore numeric function
now to drop my missing values i have
used drop any function
and similarly
to consider only closing column as my
training data
i am using i lock or index location
now let me run it
now let's once again see the data types
if we scroll down you can see we have
changed the close column data type to
float
earlier it was object now it's float
next
we will rescale our data into values
between 0 and 1 for better performances
for that
you can use
the min max scalar function and give the
range
then i have used fit underscore
transform method to transform the values
and then i am also printing the shape of
my training data
let me run it
now we will prepare our data for
training
first we need to prepare our input
sequences with 60 time steps of extreme
data
alongside the respective y train labels
next we'll be adding another axis for
the batch size
since the input for an lstm network is a
3d tensor so it will have a sequence
length the time steps and batch size
now we'll build a model containing four
layers of lstm network all followed by a
dropout layer
on the top
we'll also have a final dense layer
which is this one
all of this compiled using an adam
optimizer and a mean squared error as a
loss function
let me run it
next i'll train the data using 20 epochs
and batch size of 32 using the model dot
fit function and passing my x train and
y train data
this will take some time to run
since
it will complete 20 iterations
so you can see it has started with first
epoch and it will run for
20 epochs
now we are into our second epoch you can
see the loss that was incurred during
the training of the first epoch
you